What if social media
could save lives?
Right now, there are
literally millions
of people
struggling with
undiagnosed
medical conditions.
I’m Breteni,
Kamiyah’s mom.
She’s 6 years old.
She’s paralyzed anywhere
from 3 to 20 seconds,
over 300 times a day.
I was in the Gulf War.
I served 8 years,
and now
I’m losing my memory.
Every time the
deja-vu happens
I feel my eyes roll
in the back of my head,
and then I flatline.
Sadie has this
incurable disease,
that the only thing
you can do is, you know,
remove half
of her brain.
How could that be
the only thing you
do to a kid?
My body is going
through something.
The doctors are like,
“We can’t help you.”
I want to know if
somebody else has this.
They need
something different.
The kind of thinking
that happens usually
outside the hospital.
I’m Dr. Lisa Sanders
and I’m a physician
at Yale.
For the past 15 years,
I’ve written
a column for
the New York Times
magazine
about patients who
have mysterious
symptoms.
But, I always wanted
to go the next step.
Using the internet,
we have
the ability to harness
all of the intelligence
of people around
the planet
to get some answers.
I was thrilled to see
that many responses.
It’s what we hoped for.
Never, ever,
ever give up.
There is somebody
out there
that understands.
The symptoms
align perfectly
with the things that
I’ve experienced.
There’s another mom
out there like me
that was looking
for an answer.
We’re not the only ones.
You’ve got to keep
a positive attitude.
It’s good news.
We can create
a movement.
There’s hope.
1, 2...
Are you trying
to kick me?
No!
I did not do it
on purpose.
I know.